hey everyone me Kevin here remember the
only sponsor for this channel are the
programs linked down below I'm building
your wealth let's get into the program
did not buy a plane to remind you about
the coupon code expiring tonight for the
programs on Building Group
if you've ever watched meet Kevin you're
well aware of his infinitely running
coupon codes and basically every video
he'll tell you that he's running a
massive coupon code for his programs on
Building Wealth and if you want to take
advantage of this coupon code you should
buy it as soon as possible but the
reality is that the second that the
current coupon code expires you'll have
another one in its place it'll probably
be for his grandmother's birthday or for
Leif Erickson day at this point his
subscribers have become well aware of
this tactic and it's pretty much become
a meme you can basically go to any of
his videos and you'll see a bunch of
comments making fun of his coupon codes
it's basically like the boy who cried
wolf when you constantly have coupon
codes running No One's Gonna take them
seriously you might as well just price
your product lower permanently and have
no coupon codes right well it turns out
that there is actually some truth behind
the Kevin strategy you see Kevin is by
no means the only one using the strategy
likely the biggest culprit is Big Box
retailers if you search for genes on
calls for example you'll see that
virtually every offering is 30 to 50 off
you can see a similar Trend with Macy's
JCPenney Dillard's and basically any
Mall Outlet that you can think of it's
not just these normal people stores that
employ this strategy either higher end
stores like Hugo Boss are even more
guilty of this take this regular fit
suit for example apparently the original
price is 895 dollars but you can get it
for 50 off for no reason in the middle
of February must be a Valentine's Day
Sale as you can see the retail industry
is full of this crap whether you look
low or high and while it's easy to write
off Kevin as a flip-flopping salesman
riding off these retailers is not as
easy Hugo Boss for example spent 80
million euros on marketing within just
the first quarter of 2022 so I think
it's safe to say that they know what
they're doing they've made the conscious
decision that running these infinite
sales are worth the reputational hit in
fact one of these retailers even tried
to pricing their products more honestly
and their revenue ended up going down
and they even went bankrupt so here's
why this pesky sales strategy is so
effective and why it's in Kevin's best
interest to continue running these
coupon codes despite the public backlash
foreign
of modern pricing strategies can be
traced back to the mid-1800s the
Industrial Revolution was in full swing
it and the cookie cutter department
stores were replacing mom and pop shops
Across the Western World unlike the mom
and pop shops these department stores
carried hundreds if not thousands of
different products trying to do the good
old border with each and every customer
was not only inefficient but also
unreliable after all one bad cashier
could destroy your profit margins so
retailers decided to start implementing
fixed prices across all their locations
in our modern non-confrontational world
this would be seen as a blessing you no
longer had to haggle with your cashier
every time you went to the grocery store
but back in the day fixed pricing was
seen in a much more negative light as
people thought that it took away their
bargaining power nonetheless as these
department stores became ubiquitous
fixed pricing became the standard a
first this wasn't great for retailers
they didn't have to worry about training
staff in marketing and they could pull
out the fairness card against any
customer who wanted a deal they could
simply say Sir if we gave you a deal it
would be unfair to all of our other
customers so in good conscience we can't
do that in reality a good conscience has
nothing to do with it but this was a
great scapegoat for dealing with tough
customers the Golden Days didn't last
forever though while these retailers
were able to Simply steamroll over
family businesses they couldn't do the
same against other retail Giants they
all had massive budgets marketing
campaigns and identical pricing so it
became extremely difficult to stick out
enter coupons if a JCPenney couldn't
stick out with their shopping experience
maybe they could stick out with their
prices there was two fatal flaws with
this idea though first of all retailers
didn't actually have very big margins to
begin with Macy's for example has a net
margin of three to five percent so there
was no way that they could profitably
run the massive 30 to 50 discounts to
get people in the door and even if they
could why should they have to sell their
products for a cheaper price when Sears
across town was charging MSRP so
retailers decided why decrease the sale
price when you could just increase the
MSRP consumer protection laws meant that
they couldn't just outright lie or
mislead customers about the MSRP so
retailers had to come up with some
pretty clever strategies to cover their
Bots for example they might offer a pair
of jeans for 100 in some remote location
in Montana and now they could advertise
in New York that's 50 for those same
genes is 50 off this strategy tapped
into our inner fomo and our deep desire
to feel special and exclusive and before
you knew it customers were lining up
outside these doors trying to take
advantage of these great why discounts
these constant flash sales did wonders
when it came to getting people in the
door but people would eventually start
to notice right and when they did it
their opinion of a said retailer would
just go down right well yes and no
people did begin to notice very quickly
actually but her reaction wasn't what
you might expect on one side yes people
did become numb to sales and they
started feeling why don't these
retailers just put up more honest
pricing to begin with but this numbness
led to another much stronger feeling as
well given that everyone is doing deals
all the time and it's not worth buying
products that are notorious for this
like clothing and kitchen items for MSRP
it's probably just a week or two until
that product goes on sale itself and
they could just buy it then in other
words discounts had indeed lost all
meaning but a lack of a discount very
much had a meaning a lack of a disc
account meant that the given price was a
rip-off and a given that this strategy
has been ingrained in our culture for
several decades now all of us fueled
this to a certain degree I mean it's no
coincidence that Black Friday sales have
grown to Encompass the entirety of the
fourth quarter and it's not random that
Amazon suddenly has two prime days per
year the reality is that those seemingly
useless these arbitrary discounts Drive
sales and a lack of them drives losses
and this isn't just some sort of
marketing Theory that's taught in
Business Schools either Ron Johnson's
disastrous Reign at JCPenney has given
us real world data you're probably not
familiar with Ron himself but I'm sure
you're familiar with this work Ron is
the architect of the Apple Store he
joined Apple in January of 2000 as a
senior vice president of retail
operations and by the time he left he
had propelled Apple Stores the 4032
dollars per square foot annually so
clearly this guy knew what he was doing
and that's why JCPenney would hire him
as CEO in late 2011. Ron was given the
task of transforming JCPenney and almost
immediately he was drawn towards their
constant markdowns like most of us he
felt that this was the 21st century the
internet was a thing people can price
check on the go so why K-pop is a brain
dead at list prices well the answer was
seemingly no reason at all so Ron went
ahead and eliminated all markdowns
across the entire company instead he
introduced fair and square pricing which
is exactly what it sounds like he also
eliminated the use of 99 in the price
tags surely none of us are stupid enough
to base our purchasing decision on these
arbitrary deals or one cent right if
anything consumers should appreciate the
transparent pricing oh how wrong he was
within just 12 months same store sales
would take climate 25 percent and the
company would end up losing a 1 billion
dollars Ron's performance was so bad
that it was literally the worst
performance of any retail CEO ever and
this blunder would put a JCPenney on the
track towards their eventual bankruptcy
I don't think you'd be surprised to hear
that Ron was fired just four months
later but what went wrong
the main factor that Ron had failed to
consider was the erratically different
objectives of Apple Stores and the
JCPenney Outlets here's the thing
iPhones sell themselves and the people
who go to Apple stores have usually
already made up their mind they're there
to buy or they're there to browse
there's not very many people who are on
the fence so the entire point of Apple
Stores is to Simply create an enjoyable
shopping experience meanwhile JCPenney
is trying to sell extraordinarily
oversaturated products in massive
upscale locations Shoppers at the
JCPenney aren't usually there with
intention many of them are just
strolling around the mall and decided to
stop by so JCPenney has to work very
hard to get these strollers to become
customers the same case can be made
about iPhones as well outside of Apple
stores
if you go to at T Verizon or T-Mobile
you'll see dozens of deals trading
discounts and of course aggressive
salesmen selling YouTube courses is much
closer to JCPenney than it is to Apple
people are watching YouTube videos in
their leisure time they want to be
entertained and may be informed but
they're definitely not jumping up and
down about the prospect of buying a 1700
course we should also mention that
basically every Finance YouTuber has
their own money course and their own
YouTube course and their own trading
course so Kevin not only has to convince
a casual viewer to buy an expensive
product but he has to convince them to
buy his product over someone else's
enter coupon codes offering a
quote-unquote 1700 course for 500
accomplishes two things first of all it
creates a sense of urgency people who
watch Kevin regularly know that another
coupon is just around the corner but new
viewers when naturally feel that they
have a limited time to take advantage of
this opportunity we should also mention
that out of his regular viewers the
people who are willing to buy his course
have probably already bought it so a
coupon code or a lack of a coupon code
it wouldn't really swag as regular
viewers in any One Direction but it does
wonders with new viewers aside from
creating urgency the listing price also
creates a high price anchor if you are
judging the course based on just its
content you might feel that it's only
worth 50 bucks but since you're given
this initial price of Seventeen hundred
dollars 500 seems a lot more reasonable
even if you're looking for a more
aggressive deal you'd likely be aiming
for 400 or 300 not 50 and let's just say
this strategy has worked extraordinarily
well for Kevin
foreign
you can argue all you want about
marketing strategies and the brand
perception but something you can't argue
with is results and Kevin's got the best
results in the space period Graham
Stefan for example is the largest
Finance YouTuber with over 4 million
subscribers and in 2021 he made it 6.1
million dollars which is an
extraordinary amount of money meet Kevin
however has less than half of a gram
subscriber count yet he was making three
million dollars per month in 2021 not to
mention he now owns a private jet now
let me be clear here this is not an
endorsement of mute Kevin or his courses
it's simply a discussion about how
effective is coupon code strategy is
despite the fact that he is always
offering one the bottom line is that
while annoying it's effective and the
only thing we can blame is our own
psychology at the end of the day Kevin
is just using the psychology of money to
sell a course about the psychology of
money along those lines I have a
question for you would you buy jeans
that aren't on sale comment that down
below also drop a like if you would like
to help my psychology and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community tickets which video ideas and
to consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Harriet and I'll see you guys
on the next one